Alright guys, so here is example number two for the monthly bias, I'm looking at AUDUSD
on the monthly timeframe of course.
So now how do you manually identify highs and lows?
So a high and a low is a pattern of three candles, okay?
The first candle is like this.
The second candle is the highest and the third candle is lower than the second candle.
So the second candle has to be the highest.
You can see we have a wick here, wick here and wick here.
The second candle has the highest wick, okay?
Once we have that pattern, right, when the candle closes, that is your high, or you can
simply just use the fractals indicator.
But sometimes fractals might miss these small highs and lows, so you must know what is
high and a low.
So over here, what we have is a purge on the external liquidity and where is the drawn
liquidity?
It's going to be this fair valley gap.
So now let's drop down to the daily timeframe once we have taken out the monthly extended
liquidity.
So now what we want to wait for is a market structure shift and right there you can see
we have a shift in the market structure, beautiful.
So then you can see price fills in the fair valley gap.
So that is going to be our entry, right?
If the fair valley gap is big, you can simply just use the 0.5 level of the fib, which is
going to be this.
So let's say your entry is here.
Let me remove the fib.
Your stop goes above the high and you're simply targeting the monthly drawn liquidity,
which is the fair valley gap.
These two lines is a fair valley gap.
Remember I drew two lines.
So you have your entry.
So let's see what would have happened.
And there you go.
Take profit hit.
You can see we have been bearished throughout these many days.
Now if you were on the one hour timeframe, now let me give you some hints.
You could have taken your entry somewhere around here, maybe here.
If it took out some high or low, but we're going to talk about that later.
Just don't want to confuse you guys.
You can use this as a bread and butter model, just two time frames, right?
Remember time frame alignment, we are for monthly bias, we use monthly, daily and hourly.
For weekly, we use the weekly for our time frame and 15 minutes time frame.
For daily, we use daily one hour and five minutes and for four hour time frame, right?
For intraday bias, we use the four hour, 15 minutes and two minutes.
We're not going to use one minute because it is not reliable.
So price gives us a market structure shift for everybody gap, boom, right there.
Let me give you guys an example for the weekly bias now.